>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY,
WE BEGIN WITH MANY FOX NEWS
ALERT'S, AN UNBELIEVABLE DAY, A
LOT OF NEWS TO COVER TONIGHT, SO
MANY BREAKING STORIES INCLUDING
DETAILS FROM THE FIRES OF ABUSE
REPORTED.
HAD A TRAIN WRECK PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH NANCY PELOSI
THAT LEFT HER RECEIVING WITH
RANGE, HAVE THAT TAPE AND MORE
FALLOUT BUT FIRST WITH THE 2020
ELECTION AND ONLY 334 DAYS, YOU
HAVE THE POWER, I DO HAVE HOPE
AND OPTIMISM BECAUSE THE RADICAL
FAR LEFT SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOW IN
SHAMBLES TONIGHT FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM.
BECAUSE IT'S FILLED WITH
SO-CALLED ELITES WHO WERE
TOTALLY DETACHED FROM REALITY.
BUT THEY THINK THEY'RE BETTER,
THEY'RE SMARTER, MORE CAPABLE
THAN ALL OF US.
OBAMA SAID REMEMBER, THEY WERE
BETTER, WE CLING TO OUR GOD, WE
DO, WE BELIEVE IN THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, TRUE.
OUR BIBLE, ABSOLUTELY, AND OUR
RELIGION.
HILLARY CLINTON CALLED US HE
REDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES.
WHILE JERRY NADLER HAULED IN
THREE IVORY TOWER RADICAL
ANTI-TRUMP AS FAR LEFT AS YOU
CAN GO COLLEGE PROFESSORS TO
EDUCATE WE THE UNINFORMED MASSES
ON THE VIRTUES OF IMPEACHMENT.
ONE PROFESSOR THAT WANTED TRUMP
IMPEACHED FOR TWEETING THE WORDS
FAKE NEWS.
AND TODAY DURING THIS DISASTROUS
TOWN HALL, COULDN'T BELIEVE
THIS.
A VERY AGITATED JOE LOST IT.
HE WENT OFF ON AN 83 YEAR OLD
VOTER.
HE CALLED THE GUY FAT, THEN
DENIED IT, CLAIMED THAT HE IS A
LIAR, BELITTLED THIS GUY.
SUGGESTING THE MAN HAD A LOW IQ
THEN CHALLENGED HIM TO A PUSH-UP
CONTEST COMPETITION SO WHY DID
JOE SNAP?
BECAUSE DARED TO ASK A QUESTION
ABOUT OF ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER
IN THE MILLIONS HE'S MAKING
SITTING ON A BOARD OF THE
CORRUPT UKRAINIAN OIL AND GAS
GIANT BURISMA HOLDING ALL WHILE
HIS FATHER, THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES SERVED AS
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S POINT
PERSON ON ALL THINGS UKRAINE.
YOU HAVE TO WATCH YOU WATCH BY
IT AND VICIOUSLY VOTER FOR
ASKING WHAT THE MEDIA MOB SHOULD
BE ASKING, A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
>> DIDN'T WORK FOR A GAS COMPANY
THAT HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE WITH.
YOU ARE SELLING EXCESS JUST LIKE
HE IS.
>> YOU ARE A LIAR, MAN.
THAT'S NOT TRUE BUT NO ONE HAS
EVER SAID THAT.
I KNOW YOU DO, AND THAT'S WHY I
AM NOT SEDENTARY, I GET UP.
LET HIM GO.
THE REASON I'M RUNNING IS
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN AROUND A LONG
TIME AND I KNOW MORE THAN MOST
PEOPLE KNOW AND I CAN GET THINGS
DONE.
THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING.
YOU WANT TO CHECK MY SHAPE ON
IT, LET'S DO PUSH-UPS, DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO.
NO ONE HAS SAID MY SON HAVE
ANYTHING WRONG AND NO ONE HAS
EVER SAID IT.
YOU SAID I SET UP MY SON TO WORK
IN AN OIL COMPANY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT YOU SAID?
GET YOUR WORDS STRAIGHT, JACK.
YOU DON'T DO THAT ON MSNBC.
LOOK, HERE'S THE DEAL.
>> IT LOOK LIKE YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY MORE BACKBONE THAN TRUMP
DOES.
>> LET HIM TALK.
>> ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
>> I'M NOT VOTING FOR YOU.
>> I KNEW YOU WEREN'T.
YOU ARE TOO OLD TO VOTE FOR ME.
>> Sean: YEAH, MAN.
WANT TO HAVE A PUSH-UP CONTEST,
JACK.
HOW IS HE EVEN A CANDIDATE?
VOTERS BE WARNED, YOU ASKED JOE
ABOUT HIS VERY REAL UKRAINE
SCANDAL, HE MIGHT CHALLENGE YOU
TO A DUEL OR PUSH-UP CONTEST AND
CALL YOU FAT AND INSULT YOUR
INTELLIGENCE, FLY OFF THE HANDLE
AND LOSE IT BUT HE DEFINITELY
WON'T ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AND
IF THE CORRUPT MEDIA MOB EVER
GETS THEIR WAY, YOU WILL NEVER
HAVE TO ANSWER FOR HIS VERY REAL
ABUSE OF POWER.
WE ALL KNOW THE EVIDENCES THEY
ARE, CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE WAS
RIGHT ABOUT ONE THING, YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO HEAR ABOUT THIS ON
MSNBC OR FAKE NEWS CNN OR
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE MOB MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY ARE STATE RUN
LIBERAL TV.
DOING A PRESS CONFERENCE
FOLLOWING HIS MELTDOWN, BIDEN
WAS AT ONCE CHALLENGE AS HE
CONTINUED TO TRASH THIS POOR
GUY, 83 YEARS OLD OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I LOSE MY TEMPER, WHAT I
WANTED TO DO WAS SHUT THIS DOWN.
YOU SAW THE REACTION OF ALL THE
PEOPLE HERE, YOU SAW THE
RESPONSE SO WHAT DID BOTHER ME
AS HE DIDN'T GIVE THE MICROPHONE
BACK AND KIND OF PULLED AWAY AND
WHAT I WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR TO
HIM WAS THAT IF HE GETS MORE OUT
OF CONTROL, THIS IS NOT
APPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR AT ALL.
>> Sean: YOU SAID NO, LET HIM
GO.
AND THERE IT IS, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT CALLING AND
83-YEAR-OLD GUY STRANGE OR FAT,
A LIAR, INSULTING HIS
INTELLIGENCE AT THE SAME
TOWN HALL, THE SAME ONE BIDEN
SAID HE WAS IN OHIO, IN IOWA,
ALSO CLAIMED HE WAS THE
VICE PRESIDENT IN 1976, CAN'T
MAKE THIS UP.
BUT SURE.
I THAT VOTER IS THE ONE OUT OF
CONTROL.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR
UNCLE JOE OR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE IS STARTING TO CRACK.
AND VOTERS ARE NOW UNDERSTANDING
THE INCONTROVERTIBLE TRUTH, THE
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE BECAUSE IN
2014, VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
APPOINTED AS THIS COUNTRY'S
POINT PERSON FOR UKRAINE.
A SHORT TIME LATER, ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER WAS HIRED TO
SERVE ON THE BOARD OF PARIS IS
BURISMA HOLDINGS.
HE WAS PAID MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
ZERO EXPERIENCE IN GAS, ZERO
EXPERIENCE IN ENERGY, ZERO
EXPERIENCE AND UKRAINE, 0 FOR 3
INSTEAD OF EXPERIENCE, HE WAS
PEDDLING ACCESS.
TURNS OUT IT WAS A GREAT
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IN 2016,
HUNTER BIDEN AND HIS COMPANY
FACED A CORRUPTION INVESTIGATION
BY UKRAINE'S TOP PROSECUTOR WHO
CAME TO THE RESCUE?
DADDY.
JOE BIDEN, THE VICE PRESIDENT
DEMANDING A PROSECUTOR IN
UKRAINE BE FIRED.
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY LEVERAGED AND
BRAGS ABOUT LEVERAGING A BILLION
U.S. TAX DOLLARS IN AID TO GET A
PROSECUTOR AND UKRAINE FIRED.
WHY?
HE WAS TOLD BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND OTHERS
THAT THAT PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING A ZERO EXPERIENCE
SON BEING PAID MILLIONS.
REMEMBER, VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
BRAGGED, TOLD THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE ON THAT I AM GETTING ON
A PLANE IN SIX HOURS.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING A BILLION
DOLLARS, YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
GET IT.
THEY FIRE THE PROSECUTOR AND
HUNTER IS IN THE CLEAR.
THAT IS A QUID PRO QUO BY JOE.
COULD YOU IMAGINE THE REACTION
IF THIS WAS DON JR, ERIC TRUMP,
OR 13-YEAR-OLD BARRON TRUMP, A
TEENAGER?
THAT'S HOW LOW THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE SUNK, GOING AFTER A
TEENAGER.
THAT'S HOW REPULSIVE THEY NOW
ARE.
IMAGINE IF IT WAS TRUMP
BRAGGING.
UNLESS YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR,
DON JR. ZERO EXPERIENCE.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT THIS IN
THE MOB IN THE MEDIA HAS NO
CREDIBILITY EVER.
THIS IS -- YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE
THIS IN.
BREATHTAKING HYPOCRISY AND
CORRUPTION.
THE MOB MEDIA IS STATE RUN
DEMOCRATIC TV AND NOW BREAKING
THIS WEEK, A JUDGE HAS RULED
HUNTER BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE TO
TURN OVER HIS FINANCIAL FILES,
SO SOON, WE MIGHT KNOW EXACTLY
HOW MUCH HE ACTUALLY MADE AND
HOW MUCH WAS IN THE I NEVER GOT
A PENNY FROM CHINA, HOW MUCH
EQUITY DID HE GET IN THAT DEAL
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA?
'S LAWYERS SAID HE HASN'T CASHED
AS EQUITY YET AND TECHNICALLY
HASN'T GOTTEN A PENNY YET AND IF
DEMOCRATS ARE ABLE TO PASS
IMPEACHMENT IN THE HOUSE, THE
BIDENS WILL LIKELY NOW BE CALLED
TO TESTIFY DURING THE
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED SENATE
TRIAL.
IS IT GOING TO BE MUST-SEE TV,
BUT TELLING REPORTERS HE IS NOT
GOING TO APPEAR VOLUNTARILY
BECAUSE QUID PRO QUO JOE HAS A
LOT TO HIDE AND ALSO BREAKING
TONIGHT, A BIG STORY IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" BY
THEIR EDITORIAL BOARD, SHIP'S
BROAD DEFINITION BRIBERY WOULD